want conservative Grassroots look no
further altering them in Cheshire is a
Tory stronghold its MP is Sir gray and
Brady head of the 1922 commission that's
steering the leadership race
but even here from the three likely
Front Runners people are finding it
easier to pick a pumpkin than a new
prime minister I I honestly honestly
couldn't say which one of those I feel
like that is choosing between three very
very
um it's not a choice it's not a choice
we're looking at the last few years
Boris and partygate and the lies and the
uh you know if if his name is on the
list
that it just makes it a mockery of it
all to be honest I wouldn't like to see
any of them I have like no confidence in
any of the candidates what you get here
is a sense of frustration after weeks of
chaotic politics that farmer Lewis
Claire says is crippling his business if
we could have a general election I
wouldn't uh I wouldn't say no to it I
mean what confidence can you have in the
government at the moment there's so
little competence in there and if me is
a small little pumpkin farmer in you
know Cheshire has that issue what's a
multinational corporation looking to
invest thinking they have the same
problems just on a much grander scale
uncertainty kills us
but amidst the uncertainty could there
emerge a ghost from a Christmas
selection past Boris has a mandate we
voted for him so why not bring them back
absolutely yeah bring him back can't do
any harm well
if that's the view from a conservative
stronghold what about somewhere a bit
more marginal this is crew part of a
constituency that has tossed and turned
between labor and conservative but voted
conservative in 2019 is a front-runner
here any clearer I don't really like
Rishi I don't like Boris Johnson I
actually haven't heard of Penny before
but I suppose that's a good thing
because it means that she obviously
hasn't done anything stupid I believe in
Richie sunak so I believe he should be
the next prime minister because he has
valid points last time he said that we
cannot borrow money
and put it on your on the country's tax
credit they've all had a chance
um I think we should probably just call
the general election will let the public
decide Bridges have been burnt regaining
voter trust another item on the next
Leader's to-do list
Katrina Sky News